evaluate the expression 4n to the first
power minus 2n to the 0th power for n
equals 1 and n equals 5. so let's do n
equals 1 first so every place we see an
n let's put a 1 in there so this is
equal to 4 times one to the first power
minus two times one to the zero power
every place we saw on n we have an n
there we have an n to the first n to the
first one to the first so remember we
want to do our order of operations we
have pemdas and i'm going to write it
this way just to make it clear that we
do parentheses then exponentiation
then multiplication and division are at
the same level they get the same
priority and then addition and
subtraction get the same priority so we
want to do our exponent exponents before
we do anything else there are no
parentheses here so we first want to
evaluate 1 to the first power and
anything to the first power is just that
anything if i just have any number to
the first power that is just going to be
equal to that number so 1 to the first
power is just equal to 1. so this is
going to be 4 times 1 let me write it 4
times 1
minus
2 times 1 to the 0th power now any
number other than 0 to the 0th power is
going to be 1. so if i tell you x to the
0th power is equal to what and i tell
you that x is not equal to zero what is
x to the zeroth power you should
immediately know that it is equal to one
i exclude zero because zero to the zero
power is usually undefined or for our
purposes you can accept it to be
undefined and maybe in the future i'll
do a video on explaining why it's
undefined because it could either under
sum there's some good arguments for why
this should be 0 because 0 to pretty
much any other power is 0 but then
there's a really good argument for why
it should be 1 because any other number
to the 0th power is 1. so that's why for
the most part we like to keep this
undefined
so with that said 1 to the 0th power is
just going to be 1.
anything other than 0 to the 0th power
is 1. so we have 4 times 1 which is 4
minus 2 times 1 which is 2 so 4 minus 2
is just equal to 2. now let's do the
same thing with n equals 5. so it
becomes 4
times 5 to the first power
minus two times five to the zero power
same thing five to the first power is
just going to be equal to five
so let me do that in i want to do that
in a different color
5 to the first power is just going to be
equal to 5. 5 to the 0th power is just
going to be equal to 1 and so this
expression becomes 4
times 5 minus 2 times 1 or 4 times 5 is
20 minus 2 times 1 2 that is
that is 2 and this is equal to
this is equal to 18 and we're done